and Tom what difference is winter going
to make to this conflict because it's
around the corner in a couple of months
and Ukrainian Winters are notoriously
bitter yeah
well what is making it's going to bring
bigger advantages for Ukraine
primary reasons so far by the Russian
armed forces were relatively successful
which is actually just one segment of
Russian Armed Forces this is the ground
forces
have been successful the last let's say
since April since it's since it got
warmer in Ukraine is the combination
between their their uavs or land 10 in
particular and the artillery
all antenna is uh
very rather over rather primitive
military system it's not even military
it's actually only the diffusion beings
are military grades everything else is
actually bought on open market you know
Canon cameras and Canon video video
cameras and and ECM systems everything
they installed into these uavs is
civilian-grade equipment which means
that it cannot work at temperatures
below 5 degrees Centigrade
which in turn means as soon as it's
freezing outside the Russians are going
to be blind
along the battlefield
and then they're going to have huge
problems with finding the ukrainians
along with that this is why Russians
have now rushed to buy uavs from from
Iran because Iran thanks to Chinese
support and and technical support and
know-how and even organizational
production in Iran uh Iran is capable of
delivering military-grade uavs so the
Russians are obviously planning to
replace their their own uavs which are
useless in Winter by Iranian uavs you're
going to see if this is going to be
effective or not but generally Ukraine
should be on advantage
so that's very interesting because I
would have thought that it would you
know it would help the Russians because
they pushed them back and they can and
look again I'm a Layman but you know you
can restrict you know the flow of goods
and whatever else he just thinks the
Russians are invulnerable to the cold
yeah yeah a lot of time around me yeah
but I I would have thought that they'd
it would it would help them to kind of
not starve the ukrainians out but
certainly make things far more
uncomfortable for them
I mean we have to distinguish between
Ukraine and armed forces and Ukrainian
civilians we have there are millions and
millions of ukrainians in eastern
Ukraine feeling this war on their you
know direct impact upon their everyday
life they are going to be freezing
they are going to be hungry and so on
and they are not going to survive
without extensive aid from from the west
and from Kiev and so on this is one part
of the story but Ukrainian Armed Forces
they have no problem they are already in
the process of Distributing winter
clothing and with winter equipment on
their to their troops so this is not
going to be that much of a problem
floating food fuel as you can see the
Ukrainian Supply system is working
perfectly and the Russians have massive
problems just trying to find it
you know in order to hit it for example
from the air which it caused me as
ballistic missiles and so on they're not
successful in this regards so this is
not a problem
for the Ukrainian Armed Forces on the
contrary because of the system put in
because of all the lies which they are
feeding their people for for decades
already
and because now they're starting to
realize
the extension of these slides to morale
is very low
and then you have a system putting in
regards of command system where the the
Putin is bypassing all the normal
chain of command in the armed forces and
all the history issuing direct orders
upon field Commanders
which is playing everything he's
throwing you know every single day he's
throwing the the Russian military
Doctrine and strategy out of the window
ignoring them completely and issuing
have a new orders for assaults on
specific objects and so on which results
in heavy casualties but he can't care
about this why because he thinks that
his favorites owe him a favor or
returning a favor all the favors he has
granted to them
and so this is a vicious circle in in
inside Russia which is going to result
you know in inferior debacles like this
one in eastern khaki now this is going
to happen time and again we however in
between of this such debacles they are
going to be you know periods of many
months
where the ukrainians will have to
maneuver to find such big spots in
Russian front class to in order to
exploit them that is going to be crucial
for the for the coming winter